i don't know i can't think of anything
clever to say for the intro there's no
turkey baster scene in this movie so
there is that so
[Music]
so don't breathe too is the sequel to
don't breathe which came out nearly five
years ago
time flies
man anyhow once again this movie star
stephen lang as blind war vet slash very
efficient killer in the dark there's a
whole new group of scumbags for him to
dispatch of and it sounds pretty simple
it gets more convoluted as the movie
goes on first of all this time around
stephen lang's character has a daughter
and that whole element is very much tied
into the plot but i was digging the
concept of stephen lang having to worry
about the safety of this little girl
while he was wiping out scumbag but then
the movie kept going and i felt like the
spirit of the theme just kind of got
lost under the layers of its own
[ __ ] self-indulgence the first wave
the first act i thought was great it's
the setup it's when the initial guys
break into the house i was digging this
and then in the second act the movie
just kind of
loses itself it loses itself in the way
it's the classic case of a filmmaker
wanting to elevate the content but an
execution just shows a lack of
self-awareness you know the movie's no
longer self-aware which i had a point in
the first movie i felt like it also fell
into that trap but for the most part in
the first movie it kept it simple and in
the pocket these people break into this
old guy's house he's blind i think it's
gonna be an easy job and then oh my gosh
he turned out all the lights he's very
efficient at killing people if you make
a peep he's like michael myers had a
baby with the monsters in a quiet place
and it's stephen lang in this movie
stephen lang's character he is the
protagonist of this movie be it an
anti-hero which the concept totally cool
that's fine but it works against this
movie in execution first of all now
stephen lang is the protagonist which
means he can't be full terminator in the
dark anymore when he's this unstoppable
michael myers-esque force yeah i mean
you want a villain like that that's
completely unstoppable and overpowered
but when he's the protagonist you can't
have him be so overpowered because then
there's no tension so he gets his ass
kicked a bit more in this movie he takes
more hits than the last movie and to
clarify i'm not against a movie
humanizing a villain character we've
seen it done many times before what i am
against is a movie attempting to
humanize a character doing a piss-poor
job of it and the end result being a
more boring version of the character
somewhere around the halfway mark in
this movie the momentum just grinds to a
hole they had some good momentum people
breaking into the house i was digging it
and then it just slowed down and no one
was breaking into anywhere because they
had to change locations
and it just
nothing was happening it was this family
dynamic
and i didn't give a [ __ ] i just didn't
care i should have you know if i saw it
on paper i'd probably care more but in
visual execution i just didn't care the
claustrophobic feeling of being trapped
in this guy's house was gone and even in
the beginning of this movie when you
have the first wave of them being in his
house he's not as threatening and
menacing and the villains they had in
this movie it it reminded me of the crow
city of angels it's actually what the
sequel reminds me of it's the crow city
of angels effect where you have that
first movie that works and for the
sequel what to do i don't know but one
thing i do know we should do is just amp
up all the villains to 11. all the
eccentricity all the bat [ __ ] crazy oh
meter just ramp it up to 11. only unlike
the crow's city of angels the villains
aren't as memorable because let's face
it iggy pop in that movie does still
have the line [ __ ] you bird dick and
it's a great line that's like top tier
90s line the villains in this movie just
felt like outcast from some gorno blum
house picture and they just strolled
onto the side of this movie and they
were like ah sweet let's just film them
there were some kills that i dug
absolutely but a good kill here and
there doesn't make up for me being bored
for most of the movie it's just a
classic case of sequelitis it's a sequel
that didn't need to happen a sequel
that's clearly not as good as the first
movie and pretty forgettable because i'm
not going to remember it in t minus one
day yep already forgot alright so don't
breathe too have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you